the Joe Rogan experience because I don't
cook much no no no and I don't eat
anything you know listen ie not much or
sometimes I could I could do something I
could make breakfast like what what's
your goin [ __ ] eggs I could I could I
could do something like a short-order
cook
you are clam shucker I had a bird nose
class when I was in high school this is
what open clams you know when you were
older I used to be incredible item yeah
I'm boroughs claim houses where they
killed Joe Gallo oh but they had a
second one in Brooklyn where I grew up
and no but Gallo has killed a mulberry
mulberry street there was one of
Overstreet Alberto's clean house it
became famous after that and then there
was one in Brooklyn and I was like 15
and I we used to hang around on the
corner and they were building it and
there was like a guy you know we were
all hanging around getting into [ __ ]
trouble a bunch of kids and he pulled
out a big wad of money one day I mean
like [ __ ] hundreds and he said come
here could I get the [ __ ] out of here
take them to the movies then a movie was
probably a dollar you know and I said no
no I want a job I don't want your money
and I gave them a he was mad at a horse
which was a big wise guy's brother Joe
Wow and he kind of became like a mentor
you know it was like a really good guy
gave me a job I learned how to open
clams baked clams clams for the linguine
and clams Royal clams on the half shell
you know squeeze the lemon the thing did
being around a lot of those guys when
you're younger did that help you when
you were in The Sopranos that it helped
you like sort of because you knew people
like yeah I grew up in that neighborhood
like when I grew up in Bensonhurst
Brooklyn at the time in the 70s was all
a big mob and clave big they were
everywhere and you didn't even know who
they were you know like Joey's uncle and
this is a guy that I went to Little
League with wind up doing 25 years for
murder and they were just in the
neighborhood they would just you know
so yeah I I knew that world I wasn't in
that world I went to college I you know
but I knew that world I know people that
have friends you know it's just that
kind of a place you know where you just
knew them and somebody was just telling
me two days ago the guy on the store
like Italian deli ravioli store and I
didn't know that he was a hit man and he
sent me an article and he murders new
[ __ ] guys in Coney Island yeah this
guy named Pete and I had no idea about
that and I said really he lived up the
block for me I didn't know that cuz you
know when you're a kid you know there
was like you know he was coaching the
baseball team then you found out later I
said I didn't know the guy was a wiseguy
like a real guy and they were everywhere
they sold fireworks and you know was
that the whole thing it was all
italian-american you know and it's
changed now you know it's not a little
bit of that but not as much as it used
to well when John Gotti was in his
heyday it was a very strange time for
Italian Americans in New York because
that whole area like when he would have
those block parties and and you know
people there was part of the the people
that would love him oh yeah love that to
this day yeah to this day absolutely you
know I was gone
you know I'd left for Vegas in 79 80 so
I was gone through all the meetings you
know I was in Vegas with those wise guys
you're right and I knew some of them we
talked about it last time I was here
that she character mm-hm
Tony Spilotro who was always very nice
to me I mean he was give me a 20
every time I saw it look he's alright of
my book but it's interesting character
him as a person was very strange do you
know his grandson is a badass MMA
fighter
oh no I didn't his grandson John Gotti
the third I think it is is a legit MMA
fighter he's really [ __ ] good he's
shredded the kid looks like a [ __ ]
killer
I mean looks like an MMA fighter covered
in tattoos I think he's undefeated and I
think he's got the majority of his
fights if not all of them are by
knockout wow it's kind of crazy listen
people love him I never met John Gotti
he did
a lot of good for a lot of people he
this you could only judge someone by how
they treat you right you know to me
because people how could you you know
blah blah blah hey he was good to a lot
of people but he was known to be a good
fighter to John but John was yeah he
can't that's how he kind of came up he
was very good with his hands he was you
know toe-to-toe and was pretty nifty as
a fighter he was very public though yeah
that was the thing that the later he
came but he was flashy when he became
the boss he was like this guy that like
made a big show of who he was versus a
lot of these guys like Vincent the chin
would act crazy and walk around a
bathroom why he was like Al Capone yeah
he enjoyed himself these other guys some
of these other guys he enjoyed
themselves he was out to restaurants
good
he had movie star looks at least he
enjoyed himself he had a nice family
yeah some of these guys are holed up
they have millions of dollars and they
live a like some [ __ ] one-bedroom
tenement like a junior Michael jr. he
lives like this shitty life he's got
hundreds of thousands right here and
there it's like why are you living like
that you might as well go out and enjoy
it right yeah and they still get caught
even even the guys they look like [ __ ]
they still get caught those old-timers
you know those old-timers used to just I
don't know what they did with the money
well they were trying to avoid
prosecution yeah but didn't work out
almost every mobster
unfortunately winds up dead or in jail
yeah yeah
[Applause]